but there's the dangerous and physically
dangerous things but then I interesting
one of the scariest things you did and
it's something that I just assumed you
had done before with stand-up comedy and
up comedy never done that was the first
time that I ever did stand-up and you
know I just watched your last Netflix
special even that is so good great it is
to me stand-up is the hardest thing to
do in entertainment it's different than
music when you have a beat and you have
rhythm and you go and it's like yeah
backup dancers and you got DJ Jazzy Jeff
would you have all of that it's like
you're you're surrounded and protecting
you know even with a hit record when you
have a hit record you know the audience
is going to be spaghetti no it's gonna
go well stand up that stuff out there
just you and a microphone did you get
the bug did you kind of think I'm gonna
do this again no I went out there and I
really I really enjoyed it but when I
was preparing for the standup I was
thinking to myself I would much rather
bungee jump out of a helicopter it's
terrifying to me but I can see you doing
it oh I can actually see you doing it
and having success doing it because the
beauty of it is talking yeah you got
stories you got an amazing point of view
so I think once you grasp that side of
it I'm just sharing my point of view
people are going to understand and
gravitate towards the pictures that I'm
painting because they're true they're
believable it's authentic
you had that so I could you you could
you did tell just the story about your
dad it's true my dad yeah that one we
phones oh yeah my but it was um it was a
Independence Day and the movie had just
come out it was a you know that my first
big hit movie so it's like it was you
know like 3:00 a.m. in in LA and he was
on the East Coast and he he had just
seen the numbers so the phone rings and
at 3 a.m. cost I grab it and I'm like
hello and he's like hey you see them
numbers
and I was a dad just three o'clock I
didn't see you remember when I told you
there ain't no such thing as luck just
what you make remember I told you that
pink dad yeah I remember remember what I
told you
no such thing as luck luck is when
opportunity meets preparation remember I
told you that
dad-dad I remember he said man that's
[ __ ] you're the luckiest joke
[Applause]
[Music]
you